yeah any artist if you have catalog and
you try to sign a deal and
now it's different if they just say we
just want to distribute it you know yeah
because that's a different situation but
if they're like no bring bring your
catalog over to our label yeah
that they're uh go go [ __ ] yourself is
the shortest you gotta understand too so
how i look at it as you know a lot of
people that complain about it are just
putting out too much music i'm not
assigned to a record label so why would
i not put out as much as you can because
that's where i get paid from so it's a
numbers game man yeah so if i'm getting
paid
whatever i'm getting paid off each album
why would i not keep dropping it's a
numbers game like when you're on a major
they want you to drop an album then tour
a year and then come back and drop then
because they putting the money up before
you and
and everything else you gotta move at
their pace yeah they can tell you what
song they don't want on there what
picture they don't want i didn't heard
artists like okay they want me to sign
over here but they wanted me to take off
my tattoos or cut my dreads and [ __ ]
like that i don't want to control you
cause they putting the money up so they
want you to look a certain way they want
you to rap a certain way this is what
they feel will work
i feel like artists nowadays are
at least becoming more
transparent and understanding that they
might be in shitty deals yeah inventing
that you know like we've seen meek we've
seen yg we've seen a lot of people be
like
yo i get no money off my music
because what happens is you take the
advance
and that has to if you take if you get a
million that's just an easy number to
work with
a million dollars on a major label
you're probably only owning
seven to twelve percent of your using so
much just to get that million back
because they're going you got to make
that [ __ ] back over 10 times before you
recoup it's like bro that's hard to do
yeah so that's where all the other
things the endorsements and everything
else come in that's what they living off
of in the shows and [ __ ] yeah but when
that [ __ ] dries up that's where you
would see these artists during the
pandemic like man [ __ ] my label i see no
money since and then they get back
trapping again and then they get caught
up and then they go to jail nah i think
that's really what kovitt did was it
made y'all realize yo no all these
[ __ ] for the most part you know
and these are good guys i [ __ ] with a
lot of them but when you
take that easy upfront check you're
signing off on a lot of [ __ ] in that
deal yeah
yeah i mean you got to make that thing
[ __ ] yeah they make that they're giving
you that they're going to tell your
friend what they want back
and the yeah and i don't feel bad for
nope if you're not able to make that
back bro i don't feel bad because you've
signed the [ __ ] deal
like you we're talking grown ass man you
signed a contract yeah like you you
either you needed the money you didn't
take in advance before
it took advantage but it's different
it's d i feel like
it's a it's a it's different splits yeah
yeah it's different but if you can't
sell your soul you know i'm sorry i
didn't take in advance before but i made
money back i recoup so yeah that's how
it works see now a lot of them
take the advantage imagine if [ __ ] it
off oh imagine if you only get eight
percent how hard it is to recoup that
now if you do like a distro situation
and you got a 80 20 60 40 90 10 whatever
it's a lot easier to recoup but if you
have eight percent out of a hundred yeah
that means 92 pennies of every dollar
goes into the label's pocket and only
eight cents
and you don't get the eight that eight
cents goes towards your balance that you
owe that you own and go and go in your
pocket it does not go in your pocket
you gotta [ __ ] forever to pay that [ __ ]
off forever
you gotta be [ __ ] the weeknd or
somebody you know what i mean you gotta
be
drake like you know what i mean like
it's like good luck you know i don't
think people understand like when you
look at you know i'd be looking at
people's numbers
except like okay if he did 20 million
streams times
20 times 4 000
i mean [ __ ] you know i mean like
i mean that's cool money you know i mean
but like
you know like how are you what's your
overhead yeah yeah yeah what's your
overhead a lot of these you gotta
understand too a lot of these rappers uh
like that's all they ever did was rap
so they don't have any really other
hustles or whatever so like if they get
that money and [ __ ] that money off it's
over
and it happens more often than not yeah
especially your first deal most people's
first deal is all bad
go buy chains call all of it bring all
the homies on the road all the [ __ ]
all of all the drugs
all this [ __ ] man